some of you may have seen on today's
news that a really big diamond 110 carat
that's really very unusually large has
been sold for over 12 million dollars
you may have seen the price of ten point
nine million dollars but that forgets
the extra amount of money that the buyer
has to pay so altogether the person
buying it has paid out twelve point six
million dollars and we don't know who it
is because it was an anonymous bid but
the thing which is interesting from the
point of view of chemistry is that the
diamond was yellow and most of us are
used to seeing diamonds if we see them
at all has been colorless because they
just contain carbon why should diamonds
have color Dan and has a fairly
straightforward structure in which these
black carbon atoms are joined together
so they make a very rigid structure and
it's a three-dimensional structure you
can see if I turn it over it looks much
the same what happens in color dams is
that a very few atoms perhaps one atom
in a million or very small number
exchanged for another element in the
case of yellow diamonds its nitrogen so
imagine that one of these carbon atoms
say this one is changed into a nitrogen
atom carbon atoms have four electrons in
their outer shell which is enough to
form four single bonds which you need
for the structure nitrogen has an extra
electron it has five electrons in its
outer shell so that if you put in a
nitrogen atom you have a spare electron
and that spare electron stays associated
with the nitrogen atom but because it is
not in a bond it has different energy
levels that it can occupy in the atom
you could imagine this as being
different distances from the nucleus if
you shine light onto the nitrogen atom
the electron can absorb light and go
from one energy level to another and so
what you're actually seeing is the
absorption due to this odd electron in
the nitrogen atom there's another sort
of Dimond way instead of having nitrogen
in you have the occasional boron atom
boron has one less electron than carbon
so you don't have enough electrons to
make the bonds so in effect you have a
hole or you could imagine there's a
spare electron on one of the carbons
nearby and the result is that you get a
different color the diamond looks blue
I've never seen the blue diamond but
that's what I'm told
the diamond is so expensive because it's
quite rare it's rare first of all
because it's a big diamond and then it's
also rare because it's yellow so you've
got it twice rare if you like and when
something's rare the price is really
depends on how many people want it and
how rich they are and they will go on
battling it out in the auction - one of
the wins
the reason why diamonds are rare is
because you need very high pressures to
make them and it is now possible in the
lab to make a diamond using very high
pressure and but it's difficult to make
them large and the equipment is so
expensive that the value of the dam's
you make wouldn't pay for the equipment
you started with and industrially now
people make very small diamonds which
can be used for all sorts of machining
purposes to make cutters that will cut
through very hard materials but they are
not of the optical quality that you need
for a jewel that is they look black they
don't have this beautiful transparent
color in nature the diamonds like the
one that's just been sold have grown and
the very high pressure deep underground
over a period of hundreds of thousands
if not millions of years and when you're
working in the lab trying to make
something you don't have much that much
time so you can't grow things really
slowly so that you get them almost
perfect
if whoever bought this diamond gave it
to you with the proviso you couldn't
sell it what would you do with a giant
yellow diamond well I think the first
thing I would do is to try and record
its spectrum to find out why it's yellow
and then particularly if I let Neil get
his hand on it we'd probably end up
burning it because that would be a
fitting event for such an exciting
object it's best done by heating the
diamond then plunging it into liquid
oxygen
how many views do you think we get of a
YouTube video in which we burned that
super expensive diamond we would get a
lot of views but a lot of people would
be very cross with us